Now we'll sum up the application
of dynamic programming
to the sequence alignment problem.
Recall that we gave an algorithm, which
given two sequences of length m and
n, found a minimum cost
alignment in O(mn) time.
We did a constant amount of work for
each element in the grid
that we filled out.
Dynamic programming always
relies on the existence of some
optimal similar substructure.
In this case,
it was the minimum cost of aligning
prefixes of the sequences
that we wanted to align.
The key recurrence was that
the cost of aligning the first i
characters of one sequence with the
first j of the other, was the minimum
of the cost of matching the last
characters that sequence together,
of leaving the last character of
the first sequence unmatched, and
the second sequence unmatched.